but there's still plans to have this
farewell tour once it's safe to do so
maybe i don't know you know we're kind
of on the
schedule of if there's a vaccine and
what opens and what doesn't so we could
do a vaccine tour there we go
no music just inoculations that's right
their farewell tour may be on hold but
rascal flats did just release what could
be their final episode the ep how they
remember you
how do you want to be remembered what do
you guys hope your legacy is
well you know i hope all of our fans who
all these years um
know how much we love them and
appreciate them and
how much they were the driving force
behind what made rascal flatts
rascal flats and um hopefully our music
you know has spoken for itself all these
years and maybe
it lives on way beyond us it'd be pretty
amazing
[Applause]
it's amazing to be able to as a band
celebrate a 20th anniversary together
you know what is it about the way that
you guys have worked together that have
kept you guys
making music being successful and also
being able to be around each other
this whole time the music has always
come first
i think it's always been the most
important thing we've always had this
mutual
love and respect for each other that's
always been put first too and
we certainly have had our disagreements
but i think the
affection we have for one another has
superseded any of that
we found a way to work out our
differences and realize that we're part
of something
that's bigger than any one of the three
of us and
that's really kept us grounded and kept
us focused on on what rascal flatts is
and what we've built together
do you have any regrets about
anything musically over the last 20
years any songs that you maybe passed on
uh anything that you may look at and go
gosh we wish we would have done that
differently
one song that stands out to me that we
passed on that that was a huge hit
is watching airplanes by gary allen
[Music]
that was pitched to us first and for
whatever reason
looking back we just didn't feel like it
was right for us and
with every project that we've ever done
there
always been songs on there that i aren't
my personal favorites but
you know when you're in a band you make
certain allowances and certain
concessions to cut things that you don't
necessarily love
all the time but that's part of being in
a band now speaking of doing things
individually jay you've got your own
reality tv
series with the with the family on
netflix coming up
we can't wait to come into your homes
and show you a glimpse behind the scenes
at all the chaos and the craziness of
that one right there
boys are we gonna see cameos from you
guys in there are you gonna be having
like a big viewing party for the day or
what
they actually filmed it they were the
cameraman yeah we were out of a job
this pandemic so yeah we failed you
won't see us we're behind
down on the other side of the campus